thank you Nancy
it's gonna work on your tunes again
tonight
you're always working aren't you yeah
success came young for Angela Lansbury
she was just 19 when she got an Oscar
nomination for her first film Gaslight
but she soon became Typecast as
characters older than her years sure
feels good to get back into service Mom
oh why'd you take off your soldiers soon
she looks so handsome playing the mother
of 29 year old Elvis Presley despite
being just nine years his senior
increasingly frustrated she shifts her
attention to Broadway the gamble paid
off with a string of Tony Awards for
maim Dear World Gypsy and Sweeney Todd
but spider accolades in theater and film
the small screen provided what was
perhaps her most memorable role
Murder She Wrote starred Lansbury as
Jessica Fletcher
the middle-aged mystery novelist and
amateur detective was a huge hit you
killed Mr Miles because he'd stumbled
onto Priscilla's long ago abortion
audiences tuned in every week to see or
solve crimes and Mysteries in the
seaside village of Cabot Cove Maine she
was a lovely woman to play
but it didn't require any you know
acting ability and I thought well at all
none and I I kind of
uh just went through it 12 years always
the same woman always on her bicycle and
loved doing it I wouldn't have done it
that long had I not
as a lead actress in a drama series
Lansbury holds records for Emmy
nominations and Golden Globe wins she
continued to act well into the 2010s in
a 2008 interview she said she wanted
women her age represented as vital
productive members of society
she had no interest in playing what she
called Old decrepit women
Lansbury passed away at her home in Los
Angeles she was 96.